- [Instructor] We're told
that Mael mixes 15 milliliters
of bleach with 3.75 liters of water
to make a sanitizing
solution for a daycare.
The amounts of bleach and water
always have to be proportional
when he makes the sanitizing solution.
Which of the following could
be combinations of volumes
of bleach and water for
Mael's sanitizing solution?
And they gave us,
actually they gave us five
potential combinations,
they say pick three.
So I encourage you to pause this video
and try to figure it out.
Remember, he mixes 15
milliliters of bleach
for every 3.75 liters of water.
Alright, now let's try
to work this together.
So I'm gonna make a table here.
So let's say this is bleach,
bleach in milliliters.
And lets say this is water in liters.
And they tell us that
he mixes 15 milliliters,
the unit here is milliliters,
for every 15 milliliters of bleach
for every 3.75 liters of water.
So what is the
proportionality constant here?
If you said the water is
equal to some constant
times the bleach, well what's going on?
Well let's see, what would
he have to multiply by?
He would have to multiply by 3.75 over 15.
Now what is 3.75 divided by 15?
Let me actually do it right over here,
15 goes into 3.75.
Let's see, 15 goes into 37 two times,
we have our little
decimal right over here,
two times 15 is 30, subtract seven,
bring down the five and
then 15 times five is 75,
five times 15 is 75, it all works out.
So we see to go from bleach to water
we're multiplying by a
proportionality constant of 0.25.
So we have to see which of these
have the same exact
proportionality constant
going from bleach to water.
So let's see, this next
one is 12 and three.
So if we multiply 12 by 0.25,
do we get three?
Yeah, three is one fourth
of 12, 0.25, 25 hundredths
is the same thing as one
fourth so this one checks out.
What about going from six to 1.5?
Are we multiplying by 0.25?
Yeah, 1.5 is one fourth of six
or another way to think about it is
what is six times 25?
It is a 150 so six times 25 hundredths
would be a 150 hundredths
which is the same thing as 1.5.
So this one works.
What about three and 0.75?
So three and 0.75.
Am I multiplying by 0.25?
Yeah, if I multiply three
times 25 hundredths,
I get 75 hundredths so that works.
So actually the first three
choices are our three answers
but let's just verify that the next two
are not good answers.
So let's see, if I go from 20 to 5.5,
and so am I multiplying by 0.25?
No, 0.25 which is the
same thing as one fourth,
one fourth times 20 is five, not 5.5.
So that doesn't work.
And then going from 11 to 3.75,
well we definitely know
that's not gonna work
because notice we have
the same amount of water
but we have less bleach.
Or you could say what's one fourth of 11?
Well that's going to be less than 3.75
so we can rule both of these choices out.